we collected several ideas but idea of
European gardens or idea to use this
garden structure as a basic was
dominating from very beginning such
objects called gardens was created and
given to young people when they marry
when they creating family and it's a lot
of some symbolic in it that each straw
if you take it it's very fragile very
simple but if you clever if you connect
this one straw to others and if you know
structure and if you able to create
reliable connections then you get very
strong very beautiful very sustainable
structure what the message from our
country could be to Europe we are one of
let's say straw parts in European
structure and today we have 28 members
so we decided to suggest to create 28
gardens one for each country and to
invite
europe to invite people working and use
the slips his house to invite visitors
to think about for this lounge is
necessary to create something unusual
original that people who comes to use to
slip this house would be a little bit
surprised and stop at least for some
short-time and also we included some
artworks of our classical artists am
happy because such a project to have it
realized after heart jobs is great
pleasure and a lot of adrenaline of
course it's a special job